Did you know?
There is a type of disease in Taiwan
that is extremely expensive
Just one year
It will cost
NT$53 billion
Health insurance costs
There are nearly 100,000 people
Spending money every day
What kind of disease is it?
It is chronic kidney disease.
That's an exaggeration!
The economy is bad, that's all
And you'll have to spend all your money
at the hospital.
Not worth it
How to take care of your kidneys
Stay away from kidney disease
tell you right away
Hu Naiwen is about to begin his lecture.
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
Don't eat fruit randomly
Kidney disease patients may die from eating just one bite.
People with kidney problems, please listen carefully!
Patients with poor kidney function
those undergoing dialysis, or those with kidney disease
Don't eat
Star fruit
Don't even eat dried star fruit
or star fruit juice
Some people may get poisoned after eating it.
In severe cases
it can even lead to death
These 5 types of people are the most dangerous.
For health
don't eat any of it
1. Patients with chronic kidney disease at stage 3 and higher
2.People in the recovery phase of acute kidney disease
3. Dialysis patients
4. Unilateral nephrectomy
People who are not yet six months old
5. People with uremia
Is star fruit bad for the kidneys?
Why would someone get poisoned?
Star fruit contains a neurotoxin.
Called Caramboxin
healthy people
Eating star fruit is fine
However, people with poor kidney function
Unable to metabolize star fruit after consumption
Toxins keep accumulating
It will directly attack the nerves in the brain.
打嗝、嘔吐和抽搐出現。
Even coma and death
The scariest thing is
There is no antidote for this poison.
What if someone
with kidney problems
accidentally eats star fruit?
See a doctor immediately, don't delay.
Even healthy people like us
worry about
how many star fruits we can eat a day
Please, don't eat a few, okay?
Taking three or four tablets a day is fine.
But eating a whole one would be too much.
It is even less recommended
On an empty stomach
Or you eat it every day
Because star fruit contains a lot of oxalic acid.
Oxalic acid can affect calcium absorption.
Moreover, oxalic acid binds with calcium.
Becoming oxalic acid stones
It might even damage your bones.
I will tell you about the dietary restrictions
for kidney patients later
Be sure to watch until the end!
Taking a bath + massaging one acupoint on the lower back
Detoxification and Kidney Reversal
The most frightening thing about kidney disease
is that it often has almost no symptoms in its early stages
Sixty percent of people are diagnosed at an advanced stage when they are examined.
The patients I see in my clinical practice
These symptoms can be seen
when kidney function is severely impaired
1. Smells like urine on body
2. Dark lips
3. Bad breath
4. Dark red tongue
5. Thick, white, and dirty tongue coating
Chronic kidney disease is most likely
to affect these three types of people
People with diabetes, high blood pressure, or gout
Diabetic patients make up the majority of dialysis patients.
Therefore, it is essential to control it properly.
Otherwise, kidneys will fail prematurely.
That would be a huge problem
How to improve kidney function?
Here are two simple ways
to nourish your kidneys.
You are a healthy person
It can nourish the kidneys and prevent kidney disease
For people
with kidney disease
this can promote blood circulation and help detoxify
The first method to nourish the kidneys
Massage the shèn yú (transliteration) acupoint
It can nourish the kidneys and yì jīng(transliteration)
Improve kidney blood circulation
The shèn yú (transliteration) acupoint is located directly behind the navel
Both sides of the spine
About two fingers wide
Massage it for 3 minutes every day.
nourish the kidneys and yì jīng(transliteration)
Promote blood circulation
Warm and cozy
The second method for nourishing the kidneys
Soaking in a bath
Traditional Chinese Medicine for Kidney Disease
It is often treated as edema
Edema is divided into two types
Below the waist
Above the waist
The Jīn guì yào lüè (transliteration) records
Edema below the waist
Treatment relies on frequent urination.
Edema above the waist
Treatment relies on sweating
Taking a bath is the simplest way to sweat.
A nephrologist shares a case
There was an old lady in her eighties
The glomerular filtration rate is only 16%
In addition to taking medicine on time
It also includes a 15-minute bath in the morning and evening
Three months later
The glomerular filtration rate increased to 40.
Blood pressure returned to normal
body aches and pains have also improved.
Isn't that great?
Taking a bath in winter is very comfortable
Expel toxins and heavy metals
from the body through sweating
It is also one of the best ways to protect your kidneys.
When a person reaches an age
Choose oil carefully
need to control temper
Next
Insert a commercial segment
Introducing a Camellia seed oil that truly understands you.
5 Habits That Can Damage Your Kidneys If You Don't Change Them
The country with the largest number of people undergoing dialysis in the world
Do you know where it is?
Just so you know,
nearly 100,000 people in Taiwan are on dialysis
There are 2.7 million people with chronic kidney disease.
That means one in eight people
has kidney problems
That's really exaggerated.
Change these 5 habits
to avoid dialysis
1. Loves processed foods high in oil and salt
2. Excessive protein intake
3. Doesn't like to drink water
4. Randomly taking painkillers and health supplements
5. High pressure and staying up late
Let's start with the first one
Loves to eat processed foods high in oil and salt
Hand-Pulled Noodle
instant noodles
hot dog
Ham
These foods taste delicious
don't they?
Eating this frequently can cause high blood pressure.
impaired renal blood flow
Renal tubules are busier than convenience store clerks
Working overtime every day
can't take it anymore after working overtime for so long.
What you can do
Eat more fresh, whole foods
High-salt processed foods
Try to exclude them as much as possible.
Instant noodle soup that's too salty
There's also ramen soup.
Don't finish the whole bowl.
Just take a couple of sips and that’s enough
The second protein was consumed in excess
Attention to those who want to lose weight and get fit
Protein metabolism
It will generate a lot of nitrogen-containing waste.
substances like ammonia
They all rely on the kidneys to filter and detoxify.
Long-term excessive protein intake
You'll ruin your kidneys.
How much protein should eat
each day to avoid overeating?
Some people suggested that
An adult's daily protein intake
should be approximately 0.8 grams per body weight
Eat too much
This actually puts too much strain on the kidneys.
Third, doesn't like to drink water.
When you go to the toilet
Take a look at your urine.
If the color is more yellowish
This means you're not drinking enough water.
This can easily lead to overly concentrated urine.
stones and infection
All are prone to occur
Don't assume that water is only for quenching thirst.
It can help your kidneys
metabolize toxins.
Preservatives, artificial additives, etc.
How should it be drunk?
Drink in small amounts frequently
Plain boiled water
This is the most practical way to nourish your kidneys
The fourth
Taking painkillers and health supplements indiscriminately
Mr. Li Longteng, former Deputy Director of the Department of Health
once said
There are no health foods in the world
He doesn't eat any of these himself.
He also pointed out
Taiwanese and Japanese
The dialysis rate remains high.
This is definitely related to people's over-reliance
on health foods
Because of health foods
Essentially
It counts as processed food
Eating too much will also cause your kidneys
to work overtime and become overburdened
As for painkillers
Some people have lower back pain.
Go to the pharmacy to buy patches
Or buy painkillers to take
I suggest you
If you occasionally experience lower back pain
or discomfort
There was no significant relief
after using the patch
You must see a doctor immediately.
Let take a look.
Fifth, high pressure and staying up late.
People who stay up late
Shouldn't you have gone to bed
leisurely
and with ease
Now,
however,
hurriedly scrambled to bed
Look, there's one.
Ms. Jolin Tsai
She used to stay up almost every night.
Until was afflicted with shingles
shingles
Now she goes to bed early
obediently, at 9:30 pm
Health regained
Skin became more hydrated
Long-term sleep deprivation and high stress
Blood pressure and blood sugar are easily out of control
Your kidneys have to work overtime to support you.
Hey, don't wait until your kidney
is out of repair before spending a fortune on treatment
That's too much for your wallet.
Is that right?
Not eating a certain food for 100 days
Restore kidney health
Let me tell you
about people with poor kidney function
The first thing to pay attention to is...
Avoid strong salty foods.
Eat too much salt or too salty food
What will happen?
Overworking the kidneys
Too much salt in the body
The kidneys have to work incredibly hard.
Drain it
The glomeruli and renal tubules are all working hard.
This will also cause blood pressure to rise.
Accelerate the deterioration of kidney function
It may even increase the risk of kidney disease.
Kidney dysfunction
It's really possible to reverse the effects through diet.
More than 20 years ago
My mother-in-law
was diagnosed with abnormal kidney function
My wife anxiously asked me what to do.
I told her
to adjust her mother-in-law's diet
I said don't add salt or soy sauce
for 100 days
And the result?
My mother-in-law's kidney function
really did return to normal after 100 days!
Yī zōng jīn jiàn (transliteration)
Zá bìng xīn fǎ yào jué (transliteration)
There’s a line that goes like this
He said, if could give up salt and soy sauce
Dàn shí bǎi rì duō yǒu shēng zhě (transliteration)
What does that mean?
It means cutting out salt and soy sauce.
After about 100 days,
many people can still survive
That’s what it means
People with chronic kidney disease
Why don't you start trying it tomorrow?
People with healthy kidney function
Protect your kidneys with these two methods
First, keep the sauces separate.
Second, use natural ingredients as spices.
When you order
tell the staff
to use less sauce
Or the sauces can be kept separate
This way you can decide for yourself
How much should I dip
2. Use natural ingredients as spices
People who enjoy cooking
suggest you use less chicken bouillon cubes.
Use natural ingredients
Onions, garlic, and shiitake mushrooms
When the soup base
You can use it for stir-frying
Basil, ginger, scallions, garlic, pepper
To replace chemical seasonings
This way, your kidneys are well-maintained.
It makes feel more comfortable when eat it.
How should kidney patients eat?
Eat 3 fruits and 5 vegetables with peace of mind
Kidney patients are most concerned about
what they can and cannot eat
Theories from ancient Chinese medicine texts on abstaining from salt and soy sauce
We can extend this to mean
that kidney patients should avoid eating foods
that are too strong in flavor, too salty, too spicy, too sour, or too sweet
So-called
rich and flavorful foods
These foods can easily increase
the burden on the kidneys
It makes kidney function deteriorate faster.
There are 3 kinds of food
It is recommended that kidney patients eat less or avoid it altogether.
1. Processed meat products: meat floss, sausage, bacon
2. Processed foods: instant noodles, potato chips, candied fruit
3. Pickled foods: kimchi, pickled cucumbers, pickled mustard greens
What are the dietary restrictions
for fruits and vegetables for kidney patients?
What vegetables can kidney patients eat?
Cabbage, cauliflower, bean sprouts, loofah, water bamboo
What fruits can kidney patients eat?
Guava, apple, and blueberry
Vegetables that kidney patients need to limit are
Spinach, sweet potato leaves, potatoes, tomatoes
They are all due to high potassium levels.
Eat less or blanch.
Remove the potassium before eating.
Fruits that need to be restricted: Kiwi, Banana
Star fruit that should absolutely not be eaten
The safest approach is
to adjust the diet of kidney patients according
to their individual conditions
I suggest you
for an evaluation
to avoid making mistakes
and to protect your kidneys